he's the - it from MLB Network Fox
Sports Sports Illustrated he is Tom
Verducci how are you Thomas I am well I
was digging your conversation about Ron
Shelton yeah I got to tell you a quick
story a couple of Ron Shelton as you
know he played in the Orioles minor
league system yep and when he's going
through all these stops in the minor
league system he's hearing all these
stories about this crazy pitcher who
threw harder than anybody who ever lived
Steve Dalkowski was in the Oriole system
I had no idea where the ball was going
but was throwing people thought at the
time like a hundred and three hundred
four miles an hour that was the basis of
nuke LaLoosh right no kidding yeah and
we just lost Steve Dalkowski just months
ago victim of the corona virus he was in
a nursing home I think in Connecticut oh
yeah yeah and another bit of trivia for
you that was filmed obviously in Durham
at the old ballpark there of course the
winter the manager of the bold Durham
Bulls that season was Brian snicker now
the manager the Braves and we need a
catcher's mitt for a Costner in the
movie they borrowed Snickers catcher's
mitt that is great well Tom you were
overhearing our conversation we have
during the NBCSN commercial breaks on
our YouTube feed about our poll question
you want to go ahead and let's just have
a little bit of fun before we get to the
nuts and bolts of baseball
basically yeah in flaming themselves so
go ahead Chris yeah it's so Tom it's the
32nd anniversary of bull derms release
what's the best baseball movie Bull
Durham fill the dreams the natural major
league yeah that's a great for you got
there I would go with Bull Durham
because it just rings so true it's
hilarious it's well acted but you know
as in baseball system yato myself I love
the fact that the dialogue is just
spot-on and again it's because ron
shelton lived it spoke the language
loved all the other ones too natural I
thought the cinematography was just
probably the best of the baseball movies
but soup to nuts
I'd go at Boulder Oh would you
because again Tom I know you're not on
Twitter but Twitter only allows us for
would you kick one out add another do
you think we got the right for read it
off to him one more time so you
understands which of the four here Chris
yes a Bull Durham fill the dreams the
natural or Major League Twitter only
allows for four options so those are the
four you think we got the right ones
here yeah I think you do you're gonna
get a lot of pushback on people who love
to Sandlot which I mean how do you not
let the Sam what well but it's kind of a
different type of baseball movie so yeah
I like those four so basically what Tom
sang Chris is that those who wanted the
sad lot were smalls and we're killing
them is basically you're so proud of
yourself for having seen okay Tom let's
get into it here I guess
we're now at baseball baseball where I
guess we the fans are baseball the
smalls and we're telling them that
they're killing us man so what is
happening is you and I are conversing
here on this Monday morning where the
Players Association told baseball tell
us the when and where and tell us today
let's end this thing
yeah what's happening is huge
disagreement that's gone on now around I
how many months I guess since March they
came and agree on what they agreed on in
March he comes down to this the players
basically said we took a quote-unquote
pay cut in March so that we would be
paid a hundred percent based on games
played so say half a season we get half
of our salary owners are saying well
listen man we we didn't know at the time
and we left open the possibility that we
could be playing this game these games
without anybody in the stands that's
forty percent of our revenue and we'll
have a conversation later about what to
do with empty ballparks and the players
bases basically said no backsies you
know like the schoolyard game you can't
go back to that listen they're so wedded
to this idea in some ways rich is very
impressive but the players have really
found a collective strong voice on this
issue
it's not about pension or an economic
system or free-agent compensation it's
very understandable it's about a cut in
your salary across the board right so
that's galvanized them
so they're they've held to their
positions firmly that they will not take
what they call a second pay cut and
driving this whole thing kind of like
you know part of that March agreement
the players agreed that if they couldn't
come to an agreement the Commissioner
could say all right here's our season
we're gonna play X number of games it's
going to start on this date and on this
date they agreed to that and based on
everything we've heard that's why the
Commissioner told me last week on MLB
Network we're going to have a season
this year we're going to have a season
and under their parameters season ends
on September 27th last game of the World
Series no later that November first
they'll only get in about 48 games in
the regular season so that's where we're
headed listen it won't be the end of it
because the players could still file a
grievance the owners could actually
finally grievance - but it looks like
we're getting to the point where the
Commissioner does respond to the Union
by saying ok here's how many games we're
playing I think it's going to be 48
starting August 3rd and we go from there
starting August 3rd so they're just
gonna just Wow well I think that because
I'm back dating it rich that you know
the owners have September 27th as the
end of the regular season so they get
the whole postseason and before November
1st so if you back to 848 games from
September 27th that's where you get and
I actually think if that's what you're
going to do
why have just a three-week training camp
that start to get players in camp next
week this way you know you'll have
pitchers more stretched out some players
will be more physically prepared for a
season if you give them four weeks
instead of three weeks so I mean and
then in the middle of all this we hear
that Turner Sports and you know or AT&T
or whoever you want to call us a parent
company I mean it's gonna plug a billion
dollars into the into the pipeline with
a new television contract Tom I mean how
how does all of this Square that
baseball won't you know I guess take the
financial hit is owners for this one
shortened season or not come up with
some sort of way to say okay players you
get less of what we agreed to in March
but you still are made whole later on
down the road when we've just made all
this money we money's being put into the
pipeline regardless of what happens here
how come we can't do it there's enough
smart people and business folk out there
to figure this out what's going on yeah
I mean if it reminds me of it somebody
told me this years ago that the greatest
thing to happen to baseball and you
could apply this actually to any sport
is the DVR so once people started time
shifting their television viewing then
you just zap through the commercials and
the only way you watch commercials and
how is if you're watching live TV at
sports is just an incredible resource
for live TV nobody wants to watch a game
that's been taped late you're ready know
what the score is where's the fun of
that so you know baseball has tremendous
number of games which TV sees as quote
unquote content so it's a great content
generator live content advertisers love
it so especially in a post season we're
baseball because more event oriented
there's a premium the network's love it
so I think that has a lot to do about
the state of television as much as it
does about baseball specifically but
yeah it's an indication that the sport
as far as the finances go I think is
healthy and to your point rich the
owners last proposal would have given
the players if the postseason was played
to completion about 1.5 billion dollars
you know they basically rejected this
out of hand and knowing that the
Commissioner could schedule 48 games in
which they would get 1.2 billion dollars
so sticking the principle here they're
willing to forego 300 million dollars
which works out to 20% per player so
that's a virtual pay cut so they say
they don't want a second pay cut but by
allowing the Commissioner to install a
48 game season they're taking a 40 a 20
percent virtual pay cut now it's not
that simple I understand that they still
would retain the right to file a
grievance and the damages would be just
tremendous if they ever won that so it
is more complicated than that but I
think it's just I'm using that as an
example rich us on how galvanized the
players have been about not
a second pay cut because they literally
are are turning away 300 million dollars
to stick to their principal we spoke to
Charlie Blackmon on may 11th and he kind
of saw this coming to be very honest
with you he said that he didn't want the
politics to get in the way he just wants
to play baseball
how many similar Charlie could be out
there right now I think a lot I think a
lot you know as I said the players are
more galvanized I thought that the 2016
collective bargaining agreement the
players got what they wanted not
necessarily what they needed
you know they've got a lot of quality of
life issues in terms of you know chefs
in the clubhouse extra seats on spring
training buses that nobody takes extra
off day is a better travel system in
terms of day games after night games but
the economic system really wasn't in
their favor there wasn't a big huge jump
in the minimum salary or especially the
competitive balance tax thresholds so I
think the fact that they saw just
actually you're later than that that is
they didn't do great economically out of
xba
idea that's another reason why I think
they're they're taking a firm stand here
you know they found as I said an easy
principle to defend and that is their
negotiator Bruce Meyer says a day's pay
for a day work and it's very easy for
them to stay together on that issue so
Tom Verducci here Sports Illustrated Fox
Sports MLB network insider what are the
odds that all the players will say yes
then let's go that you know just tell us
when and where we want to play baseball
but you know showing up in August and
playing you know two three months and
not even knowing what the health and
safety protocols are yet
I mean we're what are the what's the
chance that some players basic that
we'll see
two-thirds of the Dodgers take on one
third of the Angels you know in a
freeway service it's a question I think
you will see some players who just have
too much a day regardeth too much of a
medical risk to come back either to
themselves or their families and that's
accounted for no player should or will
be
to play if they have underlying
conditions or family members who might
be put at risk by the husband or son or
whoever maybe going out and playing
baseball under these protocols so those
players wouldn't get paid but they would
still get service time now if you opted
not to pet to play and you don't fall
under the category of some kind of
medical risk then you would not get pay
and you would not get service time
that's a huge deal to not get service
time because pay is generally tied the
service time right we qualify for
arbitration for free agency based on
service time a couple other things to me
I've rich on that rich you're also
defying your teammates because the
majority of players want to play this is
what they do the very finite careers
they might not like how they got to a 48
game season but they want to play
baseball and there's so much I'll call
it peer pressure but clubhouse influence
that your buds are there playing ball
and training for a season they don't
want to come back because you think the
seasons not worth it because it's not
long enough that's a tough position to
defend to your teammates forget publicly
but I also think the message you sent to
fans is you as a player regards this
season is so insignificant it's not
worth your while to play why is it as a
fan so I then care myself about it if
you don't care enough to play so I
understand there's thought that it's not
a legitimate season it's too short to
really have meaning why would players
want to play bottom line is man they're
baseball players is what they do for a
living you can't get these games back
once they're gone they're gone well I
mean the Commissioner is gonna be on
ESPN tonight as part of a two-hour show
or all the major North American sports
commissioners are scheduled to
participate well what do you think
Manfred's gonna be able to say tonight
well I think he's going to defend his
last proposal me mention that each
proposal that they've made has moved
closer to the player side which
factually is correct I would argue that
a lot of it is just incremental and
clearly it hasn't moved the players at
all to to the point of wanting to
compromise but I think it will be
apparent that he's dealing with the
union that historically has been much
stronger than the union's we see in
other sports and the other thing we're
starting to see is this play out so much
more publicly in baseball and in the
other sport every sport right now is
doing whatever they can to kind of in an
ad hoc way decide how we can get the
sport back in front of people right
the return to play issue no we've never
been through this before we've been
through that after lockout sore strikes
but through a pandemic there's no
playbook every Commissioner is going
through this the baseball commissioner
is the one who unfortunately for
baseball is going through this in a very
public way
the ups and the downs you know one day
there's hope the next day long said most
days there's no hope so I think that's
that's an element to negotiations that
baseball you know and listen there is
guilty as as anybody in creating some of
this themselves but with their leaks but
it's it does hamper negotiations when
they're being done some so publicly and
we don't hear about that in other sports
before I let you go Tom Verducci I guess
bring attention to another piece of ESPN
programming to you check out the 30 for
30 romp through 1998 on Sunday night did
you check out any of that I didn't bet
it do you see in that season and all
throughout but yeah I've seen a lot of
the the criticisms of it if you're gonna
run b-roll from you know 2019 when
you're ready you're doing a dock on 1998
you lose a lot of credibility it's kind
of like for me as a journalist if you're
writing a story and you spell a name
wrong you get a factor on people tend to
look at the whole thing ask you the
whole product tends to get tainted so
those are I call the mistakes but
tutorial choices I guess that cast doubt
on it that's what I've seen so far I
will check it out at some point I didn't
see it last of them what you what what
is your takeaway from the 1998 season
because a lot of the criticism last
night I missed it too to be honest with
you was a sort of a hagiography of 98
not really delving too deep into you
know what was potentially going on at
the time they did get into it
in the aftermath but I'm just wondering
what you thought the story of 1998
really is well I think when we were in
the middle of it it was incredible and
it was fun and it was fascinating and I
think there was always at least in my
mind some a little bit of skepticism
about how this was being done I tell
people all the time I sat across from
mark and you know before the 1998 season
began at his home in Orange County and I
have some point blank about using
steroids of course he denied it but it
wasn't like the issue wasn't there at
all in 98 and we were ignorant to it but
you know what was happening in front of
us on the baseball field a ball parks
opening up early for batting practice
and having a lot of people show up to
watch the guys take BP mhm it was a you
know front and center on the nightly
news back when people watch the nightly
news right on the major networks
baseball was on the nightly news every
night did either one hit a home run so
yeah I mean going through it was
exciting and it was fun I mean there was
a lot of Architects that still had to be
done with how they got to where they
were but in the moment you can't
disregard the fact that it was a fun
ride you know I've been at that same
house in Orange County Tom and I've
asked the same question in mark 2 and
marks one of my favorite people I've
ever met in this business I mean great
honestly one of the might and and you
know the the shot that I did see last
night from the documentary that you saw
from after his 62nd home run the two
people he's hugging is his ex-wife and
his ex-wife's new husband I mean who it
really was a unique setup and his
son was there and they were all
traveling around as he was trying to
break the record and then he finally did
he did it actually pretty fast and he
didn't you know I mean I could have been
like a week 10 day long journey you know
waiting for that homerun to hit um and
then you know I asked him point-blank on
camera for ESPN 2 as well not ESPN 2 but
ESPN after he retired you know when I
received a fax from him to announce his
retirement which Tony LaRussa to this
day still holds against me you know do
you know and that I sat across from did
you take sorry and he just flat-out said
no you know and it's it's just um
disappointing you know it's like this
the whole say it ain't so
from the original natural the book you
know it really is something to revisit
again but at the time you're right like
nobody had their heads in the sand but
at the time it was remarkable it was one
of the most remarkable things I've ever
had a front-row seat for yeah and I like
and I say this is part of the media here
as you know rich a lot of people have
said that you know people look the other
way quote-unquote we didn't you know
like you we were asking the questions he
you know I thought in a lot of ways we
were very responsible by not just
accusing people of doing something that
we didn't have evidence of and again not
looking the other way because he wanted
to protect baseball in any way but just
being a journalist but you don't call
out someone's authenticity and the
reputation just on a rumor or a whim you
need evidence you know and the fact that
you know we withheld those suspicions I
think until we're able to confirm a lot
of these things I think was the right
thing to do in no way was it oh we're
just gonna look the other way because it
was so much fun I think again I think
we're able to hold both thoughts in our
heads it was amazing to watch but there
was something that we needed to get to
the bottom of Tom thanks for the time
thanks for the call we'll chat again
real soon once we know what we've got
here for 20/20 you got it Tom Verducci
here on the Rich Eisen show
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here